avant le début du vote l'ukraine et la
russie défendre chacune leur position
nous presser le bouton non c'est faire
apparaître un point rouge sur l'écran
rouge comme le sang des vies innocentes
qui ont été perdus
nous rejetons les fausses allégations
fondées sur des événements mise en scène
après la découverte des atrocités
commises par l'armée russe dans la ville
ukrainienne de butch à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu s'est réuni jeudi pour
décider d'exclure ou non la russie du
conseil des droits de l'homme une
résolution adoptée à la majorité des
deux tiers est aussitôt dénoncée par
moscou
la russie considère qu'il s'agit d'une
mesure illégale aux motivations
politiques
parmi les états membres 93 ont voté pour
cette exclusion de la russie 24 ont voté
contre comme la syrie la chine et cuba
allié de moscou ricard et 58 prix
honteuse choisi de s'abstenir je ne me
soucie pas des abstentions ce qui
m'importe c'est que la russie soit
suspendu c'est un soulagement pour le
conseil des droits de l'homme
et je suis satisfait du résultat
un seul pays avait jusqu'ici été exclue
du conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'onu la libye en 2011 lors de la
violente répression des manifestations
sous le régime de mouammar kadhafi
l'organisation créée en 2006 siège à
genève en suisse elle compte 47 états
membres élus pour trois ans
le conseil des droits de l'homme ne peut
pas prendre de décisions contraignantes
mais il examine régulièrement le respect
des droits de l'homme dans les pays
membres de l'onu et peut demander
l'ouverture d'une enquête lorsqu'il
constate des violations du droit
international